[Music]
okay very sad news everybody
this just happened today uh ruth bader
ginsburg supreme court justice has died
of pancreatic cancer oh damn she looked
like this lady that i saw in the movie
like a long time ago there's an old lady
which one's that i forgot are you saying
all
these look the same they kind of do so
this was
this is a unique situation like this
isn't just a normal supreme court
justice who died like this is like
almost a titan of the supreme court
she's like a [ __ ] statue of the
supreme she's been fighting for
some rights that people really cared
about yeah especially roe v wade but um
she was a part of that no no she was
after that but she's been one of the
stalwart defenders of that because she
was appointed by bill clinton
um but still like so that passed like
you know
before reagan wait is role versus wade
abortion
yeah okay it's what allows women to get
abortions in the united states right
so uh and that's considered like um
it's an interpretation of the
constitution which is so a lot of people
on the right are like well that's a
false interpretation because nothing in
the constitution says that you should be
able to do that
but that's what roe v wade gave us all
is the ability to to
have abortions if women needed them
right and so the death of ginsburg is
almost like the last
domino chip that could end roe v wade as
we know
whoa and change it and challenge it
people have no idea but this is going to
be the issue of the election now
like more than any other issue you could
think of before so if you were before
like vote blue no matter who blah blah
all this rhyming [ __ ] like now it's more
like no you have a reason
to vote blue if you want to because
you're like no abortion is something
that
could actually go down right let me see
so
um like how long was she sick for like
when was the last time she
she was she's been going through this
for years she's had
several bouts with several different
issues as far as medically
but this was something that a lot of
people thought that she was maybe
making progress against and then it just
randomly dropped
that she died how old was she she was 87
it's about that time
she was still working yeah so i think a
lot i think a lot of people thought
because she's
largely considered to be like a leftist
uh justice
and so a lot of people thought that
hillary was gonna win and so they didn't
try to replace her
during obama because they're because you
can step down anytime you want
it's a lifetime appointment but you can
step down anytime you want and so
the idea is that she could have stepped
down during obama and then had someone
in there younger
to represent her ideals but they didn't
do that because probably they thought
hillary was going to win because of all
the polling in chat
so this is extremely crazy now is her
seat
open or has it been trump can fulfill it
any time he wants
to be trump that fills it up it would be
trump that feels how many um
is it equal right now with uh you know
so allegedly it is because but equal as
in like political party
stances absolutely it's actually i think
the same amount of that's in monorail
i think the right actually has a plus
one right now isn't there one
independent
there was but he died and he was
replaced
and so now everyone feels like justice
roberts has fulfilled his place as the
independent vote
but only on like 12 percent of the cases
like he's mostly voted
in the right okay and so a lot of people
are going like holy [ __ ] this tips the
balance big
time to the right especially if trump
gets another appointment so this just
changes
absolutely everything about this next
election in a way that people wouldn't
change it back if trump uh put someone
in this
that see that is more pro yes but he
won't
if he wants to get reelected he needs
the right to support him so he needs
somebody like
amy berman jackson who i think he's
gonna i mean look at who he chose as his
vice
right exactly so you need somebody like
bible belt
hardcore anti-gay you know and he's a
new york
republican which is like you might as
well be a democrat anyway but mike pence
is a
hardcore right-winger so that's where a
lot of people go holy [ __ ] this could
actually change a lot of things
so this is a huge paradigm shift this
changes the entire election here we are
right now
it's friday september 18th it's six
[ __ ] 20 at night this changes the
entire election you guys have no idea
how much i have no idea i don't know
jack [ __ ]
you're scaring me well people should be
scared as so insofar as
before they had nothing to vote for like
i'm not even kidding now they're gonna
vote for abortion rights they just will
yeah is this as big
as when you put bacon on the quarter
pounder and now it's travis scott
what's not that big that's huge that's
massive so why because he gives you a
sprite with ice
and also lettuce forgot the lettuce
barbecue sauce crispy lettuce it does
change everything about this
sugar lettuce change the mcdonald's game
complete game
i don't know if i could ever go back to
the other quarter this is the travis
scott meal politics
ah yeah so we're talking about a
complete paradigm shift guys with
barbecue sauce
is it by law you you have to have an
even number of judges or
is it just kind of what's happening
where it's who wins yeah
and then they can appoint but then they
can't take out right
so if there's a that a seat that needs
to be filled they can appoint a judge
but then they
so there is a there is an app there is a
a way that you could
maybe impeach the supreme court justice
is just never happening it's just hard
as [ __ ] it's really hard yeah so that's
the president's roles they can appoint a
judge or whatever when it when the seat
needs to be life
appointment but it's locked do you think
trump's gonna appoint someone before the
election
that's probably his strategy which is so
hypocritical too by the way because
if you remember when obama was president
this is just before the election uh
antonin scalia died who was actually
super good friends with ruth bader
ginsburg they had completely ideological
like
opposites right but they're butts but
they're friends because
sometimes that's beautiful about america
is like you can get along
that's the most beautiful it's really
cool but tell that to the people now
god dang you can't uh but but you can't
even take a picture with someone on the
other
side so so trump and mitch mcconnell
well mitch mcconnell
held off appointing who obama wanted
which was this other guy i can't
remember my head
but matthew mcconaughey but no he
he that's right but he he was trying to
appoint his guy and then that guy
was trotted out and they're like he's
going to be the next supreme court
justice but then the republicans
wouldn't even put him up for a vote
and they said basically like back in the
90s you
guys did this to us democrats so we're
gonna do this to you and so now trump's
gonna be like well [ __ ] what we just did
to you guys three years ago
we're just gonna do this anyway so it's
about to get very interesting
it didn't get ugly then yes it seems
like it can get ugly if it couldn't have
gotten
uglier it's about to get uglier wow
that's what people don't understand
about it and he did tell us we gotta
rake them leaves man california look at
it
it's on fire oh it's on fire merrick
garland was the
guy's name merrick garland oh i'm glad
you it would have kept me up
yeah i could not sleep tonight if you
didn't that's
crazy man it's like one after the other
it's just
all this [ __ ] what are we gonna rest we
want we just need
zombies now we got the aliens wait for
the next news to drop dude
what do you think it is what do you
think it's going to be i'm so scared i'm
still waiting for the [ __ ] epstein
[ __ ] that's the real real i want to know
i think it's going to be next year 2020
into a skeleton waiting for justice
in america i'm sorry why does it take so
[ __ ] long because they don't care
they don't want they don't want you to
know well i mean
even regular murder cases and all that
take a long time after they apprehend
like is it
i know that each side has to have time
to build a case or defense yeah and they
don't know what the other person has and
then they have to go into court and be
like can we use this
no you can't use that because that one's
not cool can we use this
oh no you got to pretend like that one
didn't even happen it's crazy it's like
that yeah yeah so they'll be like
they'll be like don't bargain right
they'll be like hey uh so there's this
evidence that we have
well this piece of paper was found in
her house
and it kind of shows you know that she
had a list of girls and he'll be like
yeah well i don't know about that i
think that this isn't a legit piece of
paper i think you guys
didn't do your job in getting it right
it is
and then and so in front of that you
guys negotiate
which pieces of evidence can or cannot
be used
and what has to be thrown away so you
might have [ __ ] that's actually
good but it's not considered as
one of the items you can debate over or
whatever also be endless right
so there's like prep work that goes into
it there's just so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it sucks because sometimes that'll
be
a good [ __ ] case but for some odd
reason they have they find a hole and
they're like oh that's
that's irrelevant you can't use that
yeah so it's all [ __ ] up
this chick was a badass they did it at a
museum in l.a i remember they called
the notorious uh big exhibit or some
something like that
our rgb uh and she she survived
five bouts of cancer wow so she's been
having cancer she's been having cancer
for a while
so yeah this was the last straw like
time ago but at 87
to survive it even at 86 when she was
like diagnosed with this news
it's crazy so yeah so uh there's that
she was also
she also came on when jimmy carter came
in so she's been in for every single
critical decision since then
she's been a supreme court justice since
jimmy carter
i don't know i'm sorry since bill
clinton but she was she came in the
court at jimmy carter like he he
appointed her a district court
uh judge but then that's when she came
in the system so that that's a long
[ __ ] time to be on court yeah
yeah and then she got to be a supreme
court justice from bill clinton
so she was already a judge at that point
during that administration
and then she became supreme court
justice during clinton that means her
selfies were first black and white
very exactly pre-iphone that's
ancient letterbox that's why when i hear
stories like this
and i hear like my mom go oh the
generation gap man we just don't know
like how to think and i'm like shut up
dude there's people older than you that
are smarter and they could talk to
everybody and they understand the world
like what are you saying
true she was also the only chick in her
harvard class
oh wow what do you mean they didn't let
women in back then
or they just weren't smart enough yet
probably both oh okay
well my grandma was one of the first uh
women okay nice you saved it okay
i'm not mad at anyone so i could make
that make that joke because she actually
did it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which is pretty
crazy man
isn't that crazy that people are alive
today that were
in that process yeah it's crazy man
so so uh what's her name ruth bader
ginsburg yeah so she she was she was a
really big proponent for like women's
rights then in like a lot of conflict
through many decisions yeah wow which is
dope
man we should have people representing
their own thoughts and
you know their own groups like in the
past it was a lot of misrepresentation
so
you know things like like you know
people like hers what
got our society to what it is today you
know i would say since thurgood marshall
she was the most like like
representative of her group
that's what i was thinking too i know i
know you were and i know he wasn't i
know he was
oh yeah we know our [ __ ] wait that name
sounds familiar who's the girl you don't
have thurgood marshall no i think i'm
asking for everybody too
so yeah he uh he's a trump supporter he
was a running back no
third good thurgood marshall was a
supreme court justice he was
the first african-american supreme court
justice wait they
they made a movie about him did they
make a movie about him
that's the one but yeah no he's he was a
very big deal so
you should create a tick tock to educate
everyone
on history lessons you you
was appointed by reagan she was the
first to make it into
thought if i was a criminal if i was got
a point everywhere
if i was a criminal i would much rather
be tried by a white judge than an asian
judge
and if i if i was a criminal i'd rather
be pulled over by a white cop or a black
cop than the asian cop
because i feel like asians are too
strict and
he's not going to play it easy on me no
just beat your ass maybe no he's going
to give me a [ __ ] up punishment dude
they'll be like 30 years and [ __ ] and
i'm like oh no
please what are you gonna say it's fine
i really wanna know now no no we're very
good
no i'm really not gonna sleep tonight if
you don't tell me no let's let's talk
about joe's porn stuff
[Music]
you